hola de nuevo en el vídeo pasado yo
mencioné que iba a comprar el producto
cruz y el producto punto y justamente
eso voy a hacer en este vídeo ahora
entonces lo que voy a hacer es dibujar
dos vectores y si tenemos tiempo en el
vídeo voy a hacer algunos ejercicios con
producto cruz y producto punto ahora
bien
por lo general casi siempre hago algo el
forme un ángulo agudo entre los vectores
y esta vez voy a hacer lo mismo
voy a poner aquí un ángulo agudo entre
los vectores y ya con nuestros vectores
tenemos vamos a ponerle nombre a cada
uno llamemos al primero
y al segundo vamos a ponerle ven aquí
está el ángulo entre ellos teta y bueno
vamos a repasar las definiciones y
después trabajaremos un poco con la
intuición de las definiciones entonces
bueno espero ya tengas un poco de ambas
que es apuntó b lo cual recordemos que
es lo mismo que poner de punto a aquí
esto conmuta es decir que el orden no
importa
producto punto ya que el resultado
siempre va a ser un escalar y bueno esto
es igual a la magnitud de a por la
magnitud de ven por el coseno del ángulo
entre ellos y ok ahora bien vamos ahora
con la definición de producto cruz que
es a cruz b a cruz b que es eso en
primer lugar no es lo mismo a cruz ve
que me cruzan de hecho me cruzaba en la
dirección opuesta a cruz ve y podrías
verlo como bueno el vector que resulta
resulta estar volteado pero a cruz ven
que es eso es igual a la magnitud del
vector an por la magnitud del vector b y
como puedes ver aquí más o menos se
parecen a pero aquí este es x el seno
del ángulo entre ellos y aquí es donde
en verdad diverge el asunto cuando
tenemos el producto punto tenemos como
resultado un número esto es un número
aquí no hay dirección es una cantidad de
escalar
pero en el producto cruz tomamos la
magnitud de a por la magnitud de b por
el seno del ángulo entre ellos y eso nos
da magnitud además de dirección donde la
dirección es dada por este vector normal
un vector unitario y en qué dirección va
este vector unitario bueno este su
dirección se define por la regla de la
mano derecha
este es un vector que es perpendicular a
ambos vectores ahí ve así que bueno lo
escribo este es un vector perpendicular
a ambos vectores
y bueno quizás digas ok ok ahí ve en la
manera en la que los dibujaste ambos
están en el plano y es cierto vamos
estar en el plano de la pantalla de este
vídeo y para que algo sea perpendicular
a ambos debe salir o entrar en la
pantalla de manera perpendicular hice un
vídeo de producto que es donde yo puse
anotación para un sector que sale de la
pantalla era esta anotación porque es la
punta de la flecha y para un vector que
entra en la pantalla era esta anotación
porque son las plumas de la flecha ahora
como sabemos cuál de las dos es porque
ambos son perpendiculares a y b y ahí es
donde tomas tu mano derecha y usas la
regla de la mano derecha tomas tu dedo
índice en la dirección de tomás tu dedo
medio en la dirección de be y tu dedo
pulgar apunta en la dirección del vector
n así que bueno voy a hacer lo voy a
dibujar mi mano lo cual no estaría fácil
y no no creas que estaría fácil pero mi
mano derecha se ve se mira algo así
tu dedo índice bueno de hecho aquí estoy
mal porque debe apuntar en la dirección
de al entonces tu dedo índice apunta en
la dirección del vector
y tu dedo medio apunta en la dirección
del vector b es decir hacia acá los
otros dos dedos van hacia dentro de la
mano cierto y entonces queda así ahora
en qué dirección apunta mi pulgar bueno
de hecho mi pulgar lo lo dibuje un poco
en un ángulo incorrecto mi pulgar va en
esta dirección
entra en la página esto es esta es la
parte de mi mano el dorso de mi mano y
bueno de hecho si lo dibujo
correctamente
tú puedes mirar los costados de mi mano
así que bueno se ve algo así tú podrías
ver la palma de tu mano y tu meñique
están en esta posición luego tu otro
dedo y tu dedo medio va en la dirección
de ven mientras que tu dedo índice va en
la dirección de amd
y de hecho ni siquiera podrías ver tu
dedo pulgar no lo puedes ver porque va
está apuntando hacia abajo y bueno creo
que se entiende ya lo que esa cruz ven
este es el vector unitario y tiene
magnitud 1 las magnitudes parecen ser
muy similares ambos tienen las
magnitudes de los dos vectores en el
producto punto tenemos al coseno en el
producto cruz tenemos al seno pero la
enorme diferencia es en el seno porque
tiene una dirección
ahora bien intuición si ya viste
nosotros dos vídeos de producto cruz y
producto puntos y ya le echaste un
vistazo a eso ojalá tengas un poco de
intuición sobre esto y ahora lo que voy
a hacer es mezclarlos porque parece ser
que se combinan muy bien y bueno voy a
borrar aquí un poco no sé hecho esto no
era lo que quería
entonces ok lo borro de esta otra manera
o mejor ok ahora seguimos primero vamos
a ver qué ve costello de teta si miras
el vídeo de producto punto coseno de
tetas si tomábamos sabeco seno de teta
que es eso de coseno de teta de hecho te
invito a que lo sepas es a tu tiempo ya
tu ritmo
jose no es cateto adyacente sobre
hipotenusa entonces b coseno de teta es
la magnitud debe por el coseno de teta
entonces eso que es si ponemos una línea
perpendicular aquí bueno mira la voy a
dibujar entonces esta longitud será veco
seno de teta y la voy a marcarlo no la
voy a poner separado por acá mejor que
no quiero arruinar este dibujo así que
este es b y ahora pongo a así en verde o
no está mal eso entonces se me olvida
que debo poner la herramienta de línea
ahora sí mucho mejor el resto lo hago en
el mismo color para ahorrar tiempo
entonces este aquí es ven
acá está y aquí está teta de coste no de
teta ponemos aquí la línea perpendicular
a am aquí hay un ángulo recto cateto
adyacente sobre hipotenusa escote no
detecta entonces hablamos de la
proyección de b que va en la misma
dirección que el vector a por lo tanto
sería la magnitud de esto b coseno de
teta esto es este es el vector del cual
hablo es la magnitud de b lo escribo así
que esto esto es la magnitud de la
magnitud de b por el coseno de teta
cuando tomas el producto punto el cual
es el ejemplo que acabo de hacer si lo
miras como la magnitud de a por la
magnitud de b coste no de teta lo que
dices es que parte de b va en la misma
dirección que el vector a y cualquiera
que sea esa magnitud simplemente la
multiplicamos por la magnitud de a y así
obtenemos el producto punto entonces
bueno cómo se mueven los vectores en la
misma dirección esa es la pregunta
también puedes verlo como puedes ver al
producto punto como la magnitud
jose no de teta por la magnitud debe
porque bueno recuerda que no importa el
orden en que multiplicas son cantidades
escalares entonces la magnitud del coste
no de teta es lo mismo que la magnitud
del sector a que va en la misma
dirección que el vector b esa es la
proyección de a en b así que este vector
es la magnitud de aco seno de teta de
hecho es lo mismo es el mismo número que
si tomas cuánto debe va en la misma
dirección del vector a y lo multiplicas
con la magnitud de a eso te da el mismo
número que lo que va de hambre y lo
multiplicas por las magnitudes ahora
bien la pregunta es qué es la magnitud
de a por la magnitud debe por el seno de
teta entonces bueno vamos a analizar
esto si este es el vector a coseno de
trata entonces recordando cómo obtener
las componentes de vectores este efector
es la magnitud del vector a cero de teta
ajá entonces bueno puedes reescribir
esto como la magnitud de al seno de teta
la magnitud debe que va en la dirección
del vector normal n si tomamos hace no
detecta por ver estás indicando la parte
de a no la que va en la misma dirección
debe sino la parte de a que es
totalmente perpendicular a b entonces
nada tiene que ver con be o sea nada
tienen nada no tienen nada en común
porque bueno van en direcciones
totalmente opuestas eso es a seno de
teta por lo tanto tomás el producto de
esto con be y obtienes un tercer vector
lo cual casi indica que tan diferentes
son estos vectores en ocasiones se le
llama pseudo vector pero esos son otros
temas lo más importante de estos
conceptos es su aplicación en torsión
campos magnéticos y temas de ese estilo
son temas de esfuerzos o fenómenos
físicos en lo cual no importa la
dirección de la fuerza con otro vector
sino la dirección de la fuerza que es
perpendicular a otro vector y ahí es
donde es importante y se aplica el
producto cruz y también pudiste
escribirlo de la otra manera es decir
cómo ves seno de teta y luego dice es
claro está es la componente de b qué es
así que ve este no de teta sería este
vector aquí
de hecho bueno lo voy a dibujar acá
porque éste sería b seno de teta puedes
cambiar el orden esta es la magnitud de
b que es totalmente perpendicular a
multiplicas ambos y usas la regla de la
mano derecha para obtener el vector
normal con respecto aa y acerca de la
regla de la mano derecha eso simplemente
fue una convención fue un acuerdo para
saber en qué dirección está apuntando el
vector normal n aunque claro puedes usar
la mano izquierda si tú quieres pero
tendrías que multiplicar por un signo
negativo ya que estaría al revés todo
esto así que en el próximo vídeo haré
unos cálculos del producto cruz y
producto punto con vectores dados en su
notación de componentes nos vemos